bonjour christian cambon bonjour un
hommage national sera rendu lundi aux
treize soldats français qui ont trouvé
la mort lundi soir au mali c'est la plus
lourde perte de militaires françaises
dans une opération extérieure depuis 36
ans une fois le temps du deuil passé
faudra-t-il s'interroger ouvrir un débat
sur l'engagement militaire de la france
au sahel
alors bien sûr pour l'instant nous
sommes dans le temps de la peine et du
recueillement et je pense que les
familles qui viennent de subir un deuil
n'ont peut-être pas envie qu'on leur
pose la question de savoir pourquoi
leurs proches a disparu parmi lesquels
il ya d'ailleurs un parlementaire parmi
lesquels le fils de notre collègue
jean-marie mocq bockel qui pilotait le
cougar et qui est fait partie des
victimes
donc pour l'instant effectivement il ya
le temps du recueillement les dépouilles
de ces de ses héros sont en train de
rentrer en france lire à cet hommage
lundi et mais bien sur la liste
s'allonge les questions se posent et je
pense que le parlement à un moment ou à
un autre on va poser un certain nombre
de questions peut-être du reste à revoir
les procédures qui font qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de débat
annuel sur les opex alors qu'on a quand
même quatre mille cinq cents hommes qui
sont engagées que ça coûte près d'un
milliard d'euros chaque année
donc je pense que le contrôle du
parlement va s'avérer nécessaire qu'un
débat devra s'engager la politique
reprend très vite ses droits en effet
d'ailleurs dezider le groupe la france a
soumise à l'assemblée nationale disait
face à ce deuil le groupe en appelle au
gouvernement
il est temps de vous une discussion
sérieuse et rationnelle pour envisager
les voies de sortie d'une guerre dont le
sens échappe désormais à nombre de nos
compatriotes et deux maliens eux mêmes
et ce qui lèverait il est vrai que
aujourd'hui la présence française
parfois contesté en oui certes mais ce
qu'il faut bien regarder
j'allais dire tout commence par une
carte si l'on regardait une carte on
verrait où se trouve le mali le mali se
trouve au sud de tous les pays du
maghreb et si par malheur un califat ou
toute autre forme de gouvernement
inspiré par le djihadisme prenait la
main comme il a failli le faire par le
passé au mali
on voit par un effet de contamination
serait ce qui risquerait de se passer
dans un maghreb qui est déjà très
affaibli que l'on pense à la libye à la
situation en tunisie aux incertitudes en
algérie et même parfois au doute que
l'on peut avoir sur la situation au
maroc
donc je pense que il faut prendre en
considération cet élément qui nous fait
dire qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
quitter le mali aujourd'hui on ne veut
pas quitter le mali militairement
parce que si on quitte le mali
militairement ça veut dire qu'il n'ya
plus de sécurité
or s'il ya plus de sécurité il n'y a pas
de développement on ne peut pas aider un
état qui est déjà en très grande
difficulté en situation de quasi
faillite à refaire revivre l'état les
écoles les centres de santé
c'est ça le sujet ce que vous dites au
fond que cinq ans et que cette opération
cet engagement militaire de la france
défend les pays africains en question
mais aussi l'europe l'europe libre mais
est ce que l'europe ait suffisamment
solidaires de cet engagement français
alors c'est d'un autre point sur lequel
en grèce on va intervenir parce que
c'est moi je suis parlementaire de
l'otan donc je siège de l'assemblée
parlementaire de l'otan
on n'entend parler que du danger que
représente la russie
ici n'est pas un partenaire facile c'est
c'est peu de le dire mais on ne veut pas
regarder ce qui se passe au sud et on a
l'impression que seuls les pays du sud
la france un peu l'italie etc prennent
la mesure de ce qui se passe au delà de
la méditerranée
c'est la sécurité des français qui se
joue actuellement au mali faut pas
raconter autre chose aux gens parce que
et des français mais des espagnols mais
des espagnols et c'est la
déstabilisation de l'afrique n'a pas
uniquement les intérêts français qui
sont protégés parce que l'afrique est
actuellement en état d'implosion le
djihadisme gagne le burkina on voit ce
qui se passe au niger le tchad eux
résistent avec beaucoup de difficultés
donc je pense effectivement que il faut
regarder les choses sachant que sans
solution politique n'y a pas de solution
militaire j'ai jamais vu une guerre de
7-2-2 de cette catégorie gagner
uniquement par les armes
donc il y aura un moment où il faudra
trouver une solution politique et ça car
la france n'est plus en position du
passé ça ce sont aux élites maliennes
notamment et des pays voisins d'essayer
de mettre en oeuvre une solution
politique de réconciliation
et qui dit réconciliation dit
effectivement amélioration du niveau de
vie dit de donner à manger la
possibilité de se faire soigner dans
seillier car c'est le terrain de la
pauvreté est évidemment très favorable à
l'implantation des rires anciens la
question du développement
comme toujours est ce qu'aujourd'hui la
coopération entre la force barkan et les
armées maliennes et burkinabè est
satisfaisante
elle l'est au sens où un organisme le
utm qui est du reste aidé par de
nombreux pays européens là on a plus de
concours permet de favoriser la
formation la formation désormais mais
tout le monde sait que pour former une
véritable armée on a eu cet exemple en
europe c'est pas deux ans trois ans ou 5
ans et des dizaines d'années et donc
réunir des armées de différents pays qui
nous parle des fois pas le même langage
le même dialecte qui n'ont pas les mêmes
méthodes de combat
et bien malheureusement ça donne les
résultats que l'on sait c'est à dire que
les maliens paye aujourd'hui le prix du
sang le plus terrible des qu' il ya un
accrochage et à 50 soldats l'année la
semaine dernière 51 il y en a eu 38 au
burkina et il les dégâts sont énormes le
prix du sang et qui est payée est
terrible donc la france fait énormément
pour former ses soldats mais vous ne
prenez pas un soldats maliens pour le
faire manipuler les engins excessivement
technologiques dont la fois dans les
armées françaises sont équipées ça ne se
fait pas comme ça
est ce que vous croyez à la réussite du
g5 sahel qui pour l'instant
après des années n'est toujours pas
opérationnel je dirais que je l'espère
je l'espère parce que la france n'a pas
vocation à s'installer pour des siècles
et de refaire le gendarme comme on lui a
reproché sous parfois du reste à juste
titre comme on me reproche encore et
qu'on ne reproche parfois toutes les
bonnes il n'y a pas que des bonnes
intentions dans les rues proches qu'on
entend mais la france n'a pas vocation
et vaut mieux le dire
et nous quand on a vu nos interlocuteurs
malien et on leur fait comprendre très
clairement qu' il faut aussi prendre son
sort s'en sort en main et qu'on n'est
pas là comme un corps à disposition pour
maintenir l'état tel qu'il est qui ne va
pas très bien on est là pour un certain
temps on parle de 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans
mais là on est franchement dans le dans
les hypothèses meilleur un jour où les
français partiront et donc d'ici là il
faut que toutes les initiatives g5 ça l
alliance pour le sahel partenaire
stratégique que sais-je
peut-être du reste pas autant
d'institutions qu'on en crée
régulièrement mais il faudra
effectivement que l'afrique assure son
sa propre sécurité
l'union africaine a aussi un rôle à
jouer pourquoi des grands pays
je pensais l'afrique du sud etc ils
peuvent se mêler de tout ça ils peuvent
c'est leur continent aussi il ya
quelques jours à paris et les présidents
malien et canadiens qui étaient là pour
le forum sur la paix de paris ont
déploré que les financements pour le g5
celle n'arrive pas malgré les promesses
très généreuse 12 milliards avait été
annoncée pour le développement 400
millions pour la partie militaire
le président tchadien a dit clairement
que il n'avait rien reçu et ce
qu'effectivement le problème est là le
nerf de la guerre c'est l'argent
ou est-ce que c'est aussi une façon de
se défausser de ses propres
responsabilités en rejetant tout sur un
défaut de financement
je pense qu'il ya un peu des deux il est
un fait que ils n'ont pas reçu les
promesses que les conférences
internationales successives avaient mis
en oeuvre
ils ne peuvent pas dire qu'ils n'ont
rien reçu je ne veux pas non plus montré
du doigt les pays qui ont joué un peu
les filles de l'air dans cette affaire
car la france elle a tenu nombre de ses
engagements
maintenant l'argent ne fait pas tout il
faut aussi que dans la gouvernance de
ces états il y aussi un peu de ménage
qui soit fait car payer c'est une chose
encore faut-il que l'argent qui est
consacré à une véritablement là où il
convient il faudrait pour terminer faire
un parallèle avec l'engagement militaire
de la france en afghanistan
entre 2004 et 2013 la france qui a perdu
90 soldats et est-ce qu'on se demande
aujourd'hui pourquoi ces soldats
français sont morts est ce que dans
quelques années on ne sera pas dans la
même situation avec ceux qui que l'on
perd au sahel
c'est malheureusement le triste sort qui
est arrive
dans ces épisodes là effectivement qui
se souvient de nous 89 soldats qui ont
péri house been
est-ce que vous bénis encore quelque
chose est ce que le drakkar à beyrouth
par là beaucoup de français c'est un
vrai sujet malheureusement c'est le prix
de ce genre de guerre et c'est ce pour
quoi au moins on voudrait que ce jeune
pierre emmanuel bocquet laisser ses 12
compagnons d'infortuné ne soient pas
morts pour rien merci christian cambon
bonne journée
merci